hey guys Mary here at PAX Prime 2015 and
we're working with the mix to bring you
guys some awesome indie games you might
not have ever heard about
I'm here with Z and Kevin from serenity
Forge glad to be here hey good to have
you guys and you guys are gonna show me
the king's bird yeah all right well
let's jump right into it you guys tell
me a little bit about this game yeah the
king's bird is a momentum based
platformer game inspired quite a bit by
games like dust force and also the art
style of something like journey we
wanted to create a very emotional based
a very you know performance precision
base platformer game and make it widely
accessible to you know a large variety
of players yeah yeah in this game as you
can see there's a lot of you know
different mechanics that you have to
kind of perfect throughout the game and
it features the main protagonist that's
kind of trapped in this kingdom and
there's you know a whole story behind
that alright you can definitely see the
comparisons with dustforce right away
with the wall running I also saw that
you're building speed by downward
hopping on the hills which is really
cool so what you're seeing right now is
obviously someone who's been playing
this game a lot and knows all the secret
moves but this is something that any
player that once you start picking up a
platformer and giving it some time you
start to pick up on these subtle nuances
of gameplay yeah absolutely I mean the
game can be played in several different
ways
okay I'm from a casual players
perspective you know you can always
enjoy the art enjoyed the story enjoy
the game you know as it is on the
foreign advance player we have you know
speed running stats how many times
you've died how many times the executed
sentence and there were those global
rankings so if I want to have the best
speed ever for this particular absolute
level I can do that not only that we're
planning on putting in replays as well
so that players can you know perfect by
watching the other place exactly look at
them look at how can you improve and now
I noticed you guys are kind of going
with a silhouette style look to this is
that just to make sure that you're
focusing on the player you're kind of
keeping your eye where you want it to go
right and also you know being in the
game studio we wanted to make the most
simplistic art style and make it as
effective as possible again you know
games like the sports really you know
achieve the you know a perfection when
it comes to making these types of games
so we want what we wanted to makes it
make it something a little bit more you
know if you look at this kind of like
spidered a lot like like you know
journey it's not a simple art style and
all that so it's kind of like a
combination yeah you're you're allowing
the eye to naturally focus on what you
guys want it to go where you should
naturally be moving and a lot of that is
a really good level design and kind of
just just focusing the player on
naturally going where you want them to
go not with directions or text so
there's not a lot of text prompts in
this game but you can obviously already
see you guys have added something I
don't see in dough source which is a
nice soaring mechanic so this changes it
a lot because that's a lot less
predictable as opposed to a jump where I
know exactly the distance of my jumps
how are you gonna know how far you can
actually hover and soar again this is
you know everything is a momentum based
there's actually a whole momentum system
that's inside the game you know a lot of
people actually compare the game to
Sonic you kind of go through tunnels and
then you kind of make sure that you yeah
so as you can see you know when you're
gliding everything has to do with your
starting point how you're using gravity
if it kind of boosts you upwards you
know Kevin and it's obviously been
playing this game for a pretty long time
but you know some of these mechanics
take you know a lot of time to you know
to perfect from a man's perspective
you're changing the foreground on me now
because it looked like the foreground
would be the darkest color but now we're
going with this light blue so you guys
are having stuff in the foreground
that's even closer to you that's in
front of the player right I mean the
game is still in alpha stages currently
we've been changing the art style left
and right you know constantly and who
knows what will end up being you don't
know yet exactly so oh you know we still
have some time to work with the art this
is definitely not exactly final and
we're planning on making there are a lot
more accessible too so you guys have
forests level down it looks like with a
lot of stuff going on here are there any
other kinds of environments you're
planning on having for the game
absolutely I mean the game takes place
in this kingdom where
you know there's a whole story where
it's the kingdom is ruled by a tyrant
king that's kind of caging all of its
citizens and the main character here
this bird girl she will be escaping the
kingdom and then eventually you know
break down the barrier all of that you
know takes place in variety different
settings and you know let's see where
the game ends up yeah it looks really
cool so far I'm excited to see the next
environments that you guys make it's
always exciting to you feel a lot of
sense of progression when you see new
stuff right like oh yeah now I'm in the
castle area like I've done it you know
and so it's really exciting to see that
I love that you guys are incorporating
leaderboards and even replays hopefully
you know like that's not an easy thing
to add into a game I know that
especially with something like this
that's a lot of programming involved but
I'm stoked to see what you guys come up
with yeah so thank you guys so much for
showing me the king's bird absolutely
thank you so much yeah that's awesome so
for the latest on games be sure to head
to GameSpot calm